I don't know how many of you got my
email this morning,
but this is the last class and so I sent
in my email a link to the other lecture
that was supposed to happen,
but I have to go to a conference on
Thursday and Friday and so I'm going to
do the last lecture today and you can
watch the second glass lecture from last
year,
which will cover the territory hopefully
sufficiently well.
So
I usually use the last lecture to sort
of sum up where we've been and also to
talk to people about.
Let me open that up here first
about my more specific thoughts on
personality.
So I think that's probably what I'll do
today.
I'll start with with what we've where
we've been.
So
I started talking to you about
mythological representations of
personality
and I wanted to do that for a variety of
reasons,
but the most important was to place
the rest of the course in a,
a deep history context essentially
because personality is the consequence
of very many things and many of them are
grounded in our biology and therefore
grounded in evolution.
And I generally think that in some ways
the social sciences don't take evolution
seriously enough,
you know,
they don't,
they don't take the fact that we're
three and a half billion years old,
seriously enough.
It's a serious thing.
And some of that is evident
in a relatively straightforward way
conceptually in that we share so much of
our biological platform with other
creatures.
You know,
there was a recent genomic analysis,
I think,
of gorillas and I don't remember what
percentage of our dna we share with
gorillas,
but it's like 99 point two percent or
something like that,
which you know,
is quite shocking until you realize that
we share about 70 percent of our genetic
makeup with yeast.
So,
you know,
yeah,
obviously we're a lot closer to gorillas
than to yeast,
but we're still a pretty damn close to
yeast.
And it also indicates not necessarily
how,
just how similar we are,
two gorillas,
but how minor modifications in the
genome can also make substantial
differences because like as we are,
two gorillas were a lot different from
them too.
So.
So there's the biological aspect,
which is really important.
But then there's what you might describe
as a quasi biological element,
which seems to be operating in the space
between biology as evolutionarily
determined that culture,
those things are often,
you know,
we have an archetypal tendency to
consider culture as something in
opposition to nature.
And there's utility in that from a
heuristic point of view.
You can do a lot without division from a
conceptual perspective.
But in lots of ways it's misleading
because some of the primordial elements
of culture or biological.
And I think the most striking example of
that fundamentally is
there's two striking examples.
One is
the existence of structures of power or
structures of authority or structures of
influence,
hierarchies which are incredibly old,
at least 400 million years old and,
and which have in consequence being
around for so long that you also have to
think about them as part of the
environment.
Part of nature,
you know,
because we tend to think of the
hierarchical structure as cultural and
also as easily alterable in some sense.
But there's no reason to think that
given that it's been around,
as I pointed out in one lecture longer
than trees,
you know,
it's a very,
very permanent element of the
environment that human beings find
themselves in.
So much so that you know,
you can think of a dominance hierarchy
as the prototype prototype of culture,
but because it's been a constant
environmental feature for so long,
our nervous systems are built for
operation within a hierarchy and they're
really built that way.
It's not a trivial matter because you
know the serotonin systems that regulate
our emotions because the serotonin
system does that fundamentally.
It's also the system that sets up your
brain during fetal development.
The serotonin system is above all
perhaps concerned with calibrating your
nervous system in accordance with your
position in a hierarchy and it's basic
rule is the higher in the hierarchy you
are,
the less negative emotion you have to
feel and the lower in a hierarchy you
are and the more tenuous your actual
life because there's a direct connection
between the tenuousness of your life and
your position in the dominance
hierarchy.
The more negative emotion you're going
to feel and then not have drastic
consequences and those are our best
exemplified in longevity.
So there was a famous study called the
Whitehall study,
which was done in Britain and basically
what they were looking at,
the researchers were looking at was
health including mortality of English
civil servants in the first study was
done 50 years before the second study.
I think the second study was done in the
eighties.
Anyways,
in the first study,
you have a power hierarchy and home with
the top civil servants at the talk,
obviously in the bottom civil servants
out the bottom and you know you might
ask yourself what constitutes top and
bottom and some of it might be regarded
as autonomy over choices and then that.
So that would be part of it.
You can make choices so you have a bit
more control over what's going to happen
to you,
but also the probability that you have a
stable and productive place is higher.
The higher you go and lower the lower
you go and the consequences of that all
things considered is that the civil
servants out the bottom of the dominance
hierarchy died,
are younger and more frequently than
those at the top.
Now you could attribute that to poverty
relevant to poverty,
right?
Because of the people at the bottom,
especially say in the 19 thirties,
were materially deprived in comparison
to the people at the top.
Although they certainly weren't
materially deprived in comparison,
say to UK citizens a hundred years
before or to most people in the world at
that time.
So,
uh,
poverty argument is hard to make.
Although what relative poverty argument
is,
is easier to make,
but then 50 years later Britain was a
lot richer.
And so the absolute level of wealth of
the entire hierarchy moved up
substantially so that the people at the
bottom,
we're richer than the people at the
middle in the previous study.
But the pattern of overall overall
mortality remained quite similar.
And you know,
the importance of studies like that as
well as studies that indicate the
consequence of income inequality on,
on behavior are so important that they
should be put front and center in
university curricula.
I mean,
one of the things that really bothers me
about the humanities education in
particular,
although some of the social science
education too for modern university
students is there are some things we
know that you're never taught and it's
really appalling,
especially the relative poverty issue
because most of the phenomena that
people tend to attribute to poverty has
nothing to do with poverty.
It's relative poverty.
And that is absolutely not the same
thing because the first one is a
material deprivation hypothesis.
But if you think about it,
there's almost no one in North America
whose material lead deprived.
Now you know,
you could become mit.
And I'm not saying there's no one,
I'm saying there's almost no one.
And you know,
it also depends on your definition of
material deprivation.
But most people,
the vast majority of people have too
much to eat and a place to live.
And you know,
once you have plumbing and heating and
food and access to information,
you've pretty much got everything that
wealth can give you that isn't relative,
right?
The privation part of it is gone.
But relative poverty,
relative positions,
unbelievably powerful determinant of
almost everything that you could
imagine.
So longevity is one,
health is another.
Um,
and those are,
a lot of those are stress related.
It's a lot more stressful at the bottom
than it is at the top.
I'll tell you something interesting we
found out about conservatism,
and this is when I wrote,
I wrote a book called maps of meaning
along while back.
And I realized that I was trying to
account for why people are prone to
identify so strongly with their belief
systems,
you know,
and part of it in some sense was a
control over negative outcomes
hypothesis.
So partly if you have an ideological
theory,
it's a set of tools that you can use
quite with quite a bit of proficiency to
operate in the world,
right?
It's a simplification strategy,
enables you to control uncertainty.
It also enables you to communicate with
people.
But even more importantly,
to the degree that we share a cultural
system,
we can predict each other and that's not
psychological,
it's you act out the game and I act out
the game and so I don't have to really
know much about you and I don't have to
assume that you're a barrel of snakes.
I can assume that you're more or less
like me.
And so if we interact,
I don't have to be on constant alert.
And so that's not a psychological
function of a belief system.
That's a direct real world function.
And if you know,
if you listen to people like the terror
management theorists,
they're always telling you how belief
systems protect people against
psychological uncertainty or maybe the
the fear of death.
They never tell you that shared belief
systems actually prevent you from death,
which is even more important than
protecting you from the fear of death.
So there is the stabilization of society
aspect that that's a motivator for
maintaining a set of shared beliefs
because it kind of makes us identical,
which you might say is bad on the side
of individuality.
It's like,
yeah,
oh yeah.
Individuality,
it's really good on the side of not
having to assume that the next person is
going to kill you and that's way more
important than individuality.
You know,
the other thing I would like to make a
case for briefly is that,
you know,
in the West,
people think Western people are
individualistic.
That's the stupidest theory ever.
I think,
except for maybe the theory that poverty
is at the root of all these social
problems that we see.
Western people are hardly individual at
all.
All you have to do is go out and look at
traffic patterns to figure that out.
You know,
everybody stops at a red light.
Everybody crosses when the walk signal
turns,
virtually everybody waits in line when
there's,
you know,
a lineup for some restricted access
event.
We all dress the same way.
Men and women alike,
you know,
we follow the rules like mad,
like crazy.
And then on top of that,
there's a bit of fluff,
you know,
which is the things we could do if we're
free,
which we can talk about and dream about,
but which hardly in what he does and
that's what it looks like.
Individuality.
So you get that freedom.
But the cost of it is incredible
obedience and bought,
you know,
the fact of the obedience is that while
you could sit here,
for example,
and look at this,
it's all safe and everything and you can
come here with all these other weird
primates and you don't know a damn thing
about them and you know,
they come from all sorts of different
places,
but there's a shared social structure
and everybody participates in the game
and then all of a sudden,
you know,
it's basically safe.
Fine.
That's one reason for conservatism,
you know,
and for identification with the belief
system,
it's like stabilize the damn game.
So you can predict the other primates.
And a lot of people who talk about
conservatism as a political belief,
make the assumption that that control
element is the fundamental motivator
for,
uh,
for right wing political belief.
But weirdly enough,
the other thing that happens when you
stabilize a game,
let's say,
which would be a shared belief,
is that you provide a goal because a
value system,
a shared value system,
is always oriented towards a goal.
Otherwise it's not a value system.
It's not a belief system.
And the thing is as soon as,
and this is a psg Eddie and point,
as soon as you organize something around
a goal,
you give people opportunity to do two
things.
One,
three things cooperate within the rural
framer,
compete within the rural framework.
So that brings into the possibility of
victory and loss.
And also to experience some positive
emotion.
Because like if,
if we haven't unified our game,
which is basically the job of a bloody
three year old,
if we haven't unified our game.
And so we're each playing our own games.
There's no way that we can collectively
aim at something and there's no way that
you can progress,
you know.
And so one of the things that when when
you're taught about the oppressive
structure,
say of the patriarchal system,
one of the things that's never noted is
that because that's a hierarchical
system,
it's also a preconditioned for any kind
of victory and that would even be
victory over yourself if you want to be
better tomorrow than you are today.
Basically what you're doing is aiming at
a point that's defined by the value
system so that saving up and trying to
move yourself towards it.
You get rid of that shared value system,
but there's no structure for positive
emotion anymore.
So part of the reason people want to
stabilize their belief systems and so
that the environment,
mostly other people,
but also the environment remains under
control and thank God for that because
otherwise it's just outright bloody
chaos.
But the other reason is
no game,
no winners,
nothing to do,
no one.
That's I think why there's an orthogonal
relationship between agreeableness and
conscientiousness.
Conscientiousness seems to do something
like stabilized rule structures across
long periods of time.
So it kind of defines the game
explicitly and that lays out the
possibility of a hierarchy and a value
system.
And then agreeable just says,
hey,
don't get too carried away with that.
You know,
you don't want to make the game so damn
tight that the losers stack up at zero
and die.
So you know,
it's egalitarian isn't versus justice or
something like that.
That's not exactly.
But it's something like that.
You know,
everybody should go to university,
fine,
egalitarian,
presupposition.
The people who work hard and study
should do better.
Well that's a presupposition of justice
and those aren't the same thing,
right?
Actually,
they work somewhat in opposition to one
another.
So you could say let everyone in.
You enter university and fail half of
them in the first year.
And that's kind of what they do in
places like Holland,
you know,
where we have fairly structured
admission criteria,
but you know,
you can see the tension there because if
you let everybody into university then
the really smart people are being
dragged for.
They're being put into a position where
they're able to advance much more slowly
than they would otherwise.
So that's a real price to pay at the top
of the distribution.
On the other hand,
you're opening up opportunities for
people who for one reason or another
might have not done well in high school
or previously,
but could actually thrive in university.
But you see that those things,
you know,
there's two values structures.
They are,
it's not easy to optimize them.
And that's exactly why I think we have
those two parallel personality
dimensions and it's real hell when one
of them gets the upper hand,
you know,
part of it is balanced inclusion and
hierarchy.
You need to have those things operating
at the same time.
So.
So back to the mythological
representations,
I mean partly what you see in
mythological representations of reality
and we have to talk about reality at the
have to,
is the presence of something that
represents the hierarchy.
I would say,
you know,
in fairy tales,
that's often the cane wise,
king or otherwise.
And then in religious mythology it's
usually something that represents the
king or the father.
And I think that's because the primary
social hierarchies among human beings
are masculine in nature.
And I think that's probably because
while men are more like pack animals and
why aren't women?
Well,
I think the reason for that is is that
the things that men did historically had
a communal element,
like a goal directed communal element
that wasn't as prevalent in female
dominance hierarchies if something like
that.
So there's a representation of that,
of the hierarchy,
but then there's a counter
representation which is a representation
of the individual and that's another
really tight melons that societies have
to manage.
I don't want you to be too different
because if you're too different,
I can't predict you and you may actually
be a threat to the integrity of the
society because you might come up with
something so wild and so on.
Unconstrained that it just blows the
entire game into pieces.
On the other hand,
to the degree that I'm a rigid
hierarchy,
I'm going to fall behind.
As the environment transforms and the
environment,
the natural environment,
let's say,
or the environment outside of the
dominance hierarchy is also something
that's stable.
He represented mythologies.
So one of the things you see happening
is there's a hierarchy and the other
thing is there's a force outside the
hierarchy and it's often represented by
an eye.
So you see this in a variety of ancient
myths and that represents the capacity
of the individual to pay attention and
to maintain and update the hierarchy so
you have this dance between the
individual and the hierarchy,
hierarchy structures of the individual
and disciplines them and produces a
culture being.
But then hopefully the culture being
kind of pops up above the hierarchy and
then can start,
you know,
altering it hopefully relatively
minimally where,
where it's necessary.
It's very much akin to piaget's idea
that once children hit higher levels of
moral development,
first of all,
they play alone,
then they can play with others,
then they know the rules,
and then morality is following the
rules.
And now after that I didn't.
And not every child gets to this point,
at least according to Piaget,
the child starts to regard him or her
self as something that can make the
rules.
Right.
So you could think about that as the
Piaget did is the pinnacle of ethical
development and whether or not that's
the pinnacle is debatable because I
think you'll see young extended that
idea.
Although people never think about this
as a variation on Piagetian theory.
So for Piaget,
once you hit individual status,
it's sort of you pop out of the group
and then you hit individual status.
It's not like you're a rule breaker
because you can follow the rules and
usually do,
but you can observe them and modify them
when necessary.
It's almost exactly what your
consciousness does to your own internal
neural structure.
So for example,
imagine you're playing a piano,
you know,
and you've automatized most of it,
so you've built little machines in the
back of your head to take care of the,
of the trills,
let's say in the Arpeggios and you make
a mistake or your consciousness picks up
the mistake and then you slow down what
you're doing and observe yourself for
the motor errors and then you correct
them,
which is difficult.
And then you practice and practice and
practice and practice and practice and
you automate the new routine and then
you go on and so what consciousness is
doing is watching output and when
there's a mismatch between what you're
aiming at and what happens,
you stop.
That's basically anxiety.
You make your error correction and that
fixes the hierarchy and then you go on,
well that's really the relationship of
the individual to society as well.
Now you push that idea a fair bit
further and I might as well tell you
about this.
We never discussed this in our,
in our section on Yom,
but it's pretty interesting.
See if I can get this right.
Okay.
So young basically presumed,
presumed that as you were socialized,
you developed that persona and the
persona was you in so far as you're
socialized,
now you can see persona,
persona.
When you listen to someone who's very,
very concerned with their appearance and
whose,
whose speech is somewhat false as a
consequence,
you know,
so they don't seem genuine.
They seem to polished,
let's say,
or something like that.
You know,
there's not a lot of emotion,
for example,
in their speech,
they're very self contained and
concerned with their public appearance,
which it seems also to be a very
desirable consequences.
Spending too much time in social media
because it's all persona development,
tate's.
It's not.
It's not necessarily a good thing.
It does seem to be associated with
higher rates of depression anyways.
Your,
your persona is you as socialized,
being so young would say,
yeah,
obviously you can be socialized and what
that means is some of you is invited out
to play and to develop,
but a lot of years left on
differentiated or even forbidden.
So for example,
this happens with agreeable people.
Agreeable people think aggression is
wrong.
Well that's not very useful because
first of all it's not wrong and second
of all because they have the for
aggression and so if that isn't brought
out to play,
it sits at home and it's closet and gets
all war advanced and only comes out,
you know,
at night to cause trouble.
And so one of the things you would say
as well,
this is part of the exploration of the
shadow,
is there's going to be us persona and
then there's this mishmash of
undeveloped and resentful,
um,
potential roughly speaking,
and your job is to transmute your moral
system and integrate all that stuff that
was rejected into your personality.
And that's often involves a descent into
the underworld and a rebirth.
And that's another mythological motif.
So his idea was
you can think about it this way.
So Piaget said
at the last step of moral development,
you view yourself as someone who could
alter the rules and young would say,
wait a minute,
there's another point in that not only
do you alter the rules,
you alter them so that you can include
things that were denied or forbidden by
the previous system of rules.
And so it's a more inclusive game.
And part of what it includes is those
parts of you that you'd cast off because
they were socially inappropriate.
So and often you'll Freud's comment
about that sort of thing was that was
often sexuality and aggression,
partly because those are kind of
individual in nature and they're kind of
harder to integrate into a social group
and people will take offense to them.
I mean,
look what's happening on college
campuses.
Universities are spending more time
worrying about sexual assault.
Then they are worrying about education
and the reason for that is it's the
reason we're just describing is that
sexuality and aggression are very hard
to integrate,
so they remain on outside.
Now you might say,
suppress it for Christ's sake.
You know,
gate your sexuality under control and
eradicate your aggression.
That's a stupid idea because we know
what happens when you do that.
You know,
you turn into a little milk saw he sort
of creature with a tremendous amount of
resentment and then you sporadically
explode that hardly.
Plus you're denying yourself immense
depth in your personality.
You know,
like a person who has repressed their
aggression,
their sexuality generally is just dull
as you can possibly imagine.
You don't even want to talk to them.
Whereas someone who has that integrated
there are far more interesting,
you know,
because there is a provocative element
and the teasing element and a dangerous
element and,
and a colorful element and all of those
things that make social interactions
much more interesting.
It's,
it's,
you know,
you're playing with fire at that point
in your personality development,
but human beings are born into play with
fire,
so you don't want to deny yourself that.
So anyway,
so young's idea of continued moral
development was know,
hold the oppressed self out of
captivity,
so to speak.
Notice what you're doing,
you know,
partly to refuse to take responsibility,
but also partly just to tame yourself so
that you're at least not annoying and
get that other stuff up into the game.
So he would think of that at least in
part as the union of the,
let's say,
the Union of the articulated itself with
the unarticulated itself,
a lot of which would be grounded in
emotion and motivation.
So okay,
so that's.
He thought of that as a conjunction
conjunction number one.
So that's the bringing together of
spirit and soul or or articulated self
at the end,
articulate itself,
something like that.
So now you're an organized from the
perspective of your psyche,
but then there's another staff and so
now you think of that as an organized
thing.
The next step is to integrate that with
your body and that basically means not
only to have that integrated state of
being as a,
as a,
as a belief system and and system of
representation,
that perception,
but also to act it out in the world
because it's one thing to know
something,
it's another thing to do it,
but if you really know it,
there's no difference between knowing it
and doing it.
Okay?
So then your body and your,
your mind and your body are unified.
And then there's a third step after that
which is really quite complex.
And this is where you start to shade
into phenomenological perspective.
So you know,
when we were talking about
phenomenology,
one of the things I pointed out was that
the phenomenologists are,
they're playing a,
you could say they're playing a complex
philosophical game and the game is what
if that.
What if is okay,
forget about the idea of subjective and
objective.
Just forget about it for a moment.
Okay,
we'll start with a new set of
presuppositions.
The presuppositions are that everything
you experience is real and everything
you experience is you.
So you say reality is experience,
but there's an implication to that.
And the implication is that in so far as
you're part of my experience,
the separation between us is illusory
and so the next stage that young
proposed was that the integrated itself
eliminates the distinction between self
and other.
So that would be.
That would be recognition.
For example,
and everyone already knows this,
that it's pretty hard for me to be
stable and happy if I see you miserable
and suffering well,
why is that?
Well,
it's because in so far as I encountered
you,
at least your misery and suffering is my
misery and suffering.
You know,
unless I'm psychopathic.
To the nth degree,
and so the idea that and that has to be
taken care of.
Well and you certainly see this in the
realm of the family.
You know if you're in a family and one
of your family members is you know not
doing well in a manner they can't help
or not doing well in a manner that can
help the probability that that's going
to have a direct bearing on your quality
of being is 100 percent.
In fact,
it might be the prime determinant and so
then you can seriously ask yourself what
makes you think you're separate?
And you know a phenomenologist would
say,
well that's your assumption that the
subject object divide is absolute.
That's what makes you think you're
separate.
And so the final step,
it's kind of akin to a Dostoevsky idea.
Dostoevsky positive in one of these
weird sort of transcendent moments that
everything that happened to you was not
only your fault,
but everything that happened to everyone
was your fault and he didn't mean it
precisely like that.
He meant it more like everything that
happens to you is your responsibility
and everything that happens to everyone
else is also your responsibility know,
and that's it.
Well,
it's an insane claim to some degree
because it broadens the realm of your
responsibility out to unlimited reach,
but,
but life isn't insane thing and so
there's no reason to assume that just
because of that,
you know,
seems exaggerated to the point if your
rationality that it's wrong.
There's lots of things about life that
are exaggerated to the point of
irrationality,
like the fundamental structure of life.
Israel is irrational.
You,
you're born arbitrarily.
There you are in your particular time
and place.
You live in accordance with your talents
and limitations and then at the end of
that,
there's no you anymore.
It's like,
good,
good luck.
Make an act rational like it's
intrinsically irrational.
You know,
in one of the things that really
advanced theories of human development
posit is that to answer in irrational
question,
you need an irrational answer and I
think that's exactly right.
You know,
if,
if life is an impossible burden,
which is clearly the case,
then you need an impossible goal to set
against it,
to justify it and part of that might be,
well,
you know,
get your act together,
improve the quality of being around you,
but then that starts to,
you know,
stretch its tentacles out to include
more and more people.
And so,
you know,
one of the things I've thought about for
a long time is
there's this proclivity of people to
flee into,
let's say nihilism for,
for every good reason under the books or
ideological possession and the
alternative to those two things you
might think of as chaos.
So.
Well nihilism is sort of a form of chaos
anyways.
It's not surprising that people become
nihilistic plus it's easy and it's not
surprising that they become
ideologically possessed.
Plus it's easy.
The question is,
is there any reasonable alternative to
that?
You know,
when,
if you read people like Ernest Becker
who wrote a book called the denial of
death,
he was a hyper Friday and really his
whole hypothesis like the terror
management theorists who derive their
ideas from becker by the way,
is that everything people do is
illusory.
You know,
no matter what it is,
it's an illusion.
And so the fundamental underlying
reality of human life is that it's
hopeless.
Well,
God,
you know,
that's a hell of a conclusion to draw.
And I think it's,
I think it's clearly the wrong
conclusion because it leads to,
it leads to places you just do not want
to go.
And for me that's enough evidence that
there's something wrong with it.
You know,
like if you're following a path and it
leads to Auschwitz,
I would say,
hey,
there's something wrong with that path.
And you might say,
well the whole paths are equally absurd.
It's like,
yeah,
okay.
But some of them really hurt and you
know,
maybe we could do without those.
And I think it's a very different,
it's very difficult to dispute that as
far.
I mean,
you can,
but what you have to say then is all the
pain and suffering in the world.
It doesn't matter.
You know,
along with all the good stuff,
you can make that irrelevant right away
just by doubt,
but you're really going to take the next
step and say,
you know,
all that human induced unnecessary pain
and suffering is actually meaningless
and irrelevant.
It's like,
I think,
yeah,
put that person in jail now you know,
before they do something really
dangerous,
while I don't really mean that,
but you get,
you get the point is that you,
you draw a conclusion like that,
which is a logical conclusion of
nihilism.
You draw a conclusion like that.
It's like all,
all bets are off for you.
So there's something that just seems to
be wrong.
It just seems wrong.
That conclusion.
And so then one of the things you might
ask,
it's okay,
that doesn't seem very good.
What's the opposite of that?
So one of the things that I've really
been trying to figure out is what is the
opposite of the path that leads to
Auschwitz?
You know,
once we can agree that that's a bad
path.
Okay,
fine.
We've got a bad identified that implies
the reverse.
Good Path.
It doesn't define it though,
right?
It just implies it.
So the implication would be whatever is
least likely to lead you,
there is defacto good,
or at least you could.
You've basically identified the
territory and it seems to me that the
opposite of not caring about anyone and
wishing perhaps for their painful
destruction is something like caring for
everyone and wishing for their universal
betterment,
something like that.
And that seems to me to be associated
with the idea of improving being itself
and that means yours and your families
and your communities and far out as you
can reach probably starting with the
local,
you know,
until you get yourself all practice.
And so that seems to be to be an
impossible aim in some sense and that's
actually a good thing because the,
the psychological consequences of
pursuing an impossibly good goal are
that everything you do starts to become
meaningful because it's related
intelligibly to that goal.
And you have a structure within which
you can grapple with uncertainty,
you know,
because if someone says,
well even you says,
well why do you bother with that?
You can say,
well,
because of this and this and this and
this and this and this,
and then it leads down to Auschwitz and
so we're not going there and that's why
I'm doing this.
And that's a,
that's a hell of a tough argument to
argue yourself out of.
And you know,
one of the things you really need in
life is an argument for life that you
cannot dispute,
you know,
because otherwise you're playing like
the existentialists would say with this
constant recurrence of existential doubt
and that paralyzes us and cripples you
and it makes you weak.
And so and worse,
you know,
it's,
it works.
You can end up with so much self
contempt just because of who you are as
a creature that you're unconsciously
wishing for.
You know,
absolute denial.
I see this in many,
many places,
but one of the things I've seen it most
frequently probably in the last 30 years
is the insistence on the part of certain
certain parties who are at least in
principle,
concerned with environmental issues that
the planet would be better off with no
people on it.
It's like I think,
well the first thing I think is,
well let's start with you,
but the next thing I think is really
that's really what you think.
It's like,
you know,
if you,
you,
you don't have to go very far down from
a psychoanalytic perspective into the
dream underlying a statement like that
before you see that it is a sort of
dream that you did not want to have
anything at all to do with because
there's an actively genocidal component
to it and it's based in loading of
humanity,
self-loathing,
but also low thing on the entire
species.
It's like
better be aware of that sort of
thinking,
which is not to say that,
you know,
we don't have some things that we could
clean up,
you know,
but you know,
little sympathy for humanity wouldn't be
a bad thing.
We do have a relatively hard time of it
after all,
which is also something the
existentialists know.
They're nice corrective to freud because
Freud says,
hey,
you're probably healthy unless something
terrible has happened to you,
you know,
and the existentialists called alarm
come along and say,
yeah,
but something terrible happens to
everyone.
So you know,
existence itself is sufficient cause for
human insanity.
And you know,
I basically by that I think everyone has
an impossible existential and moral
burden.
It's a condition of life.
And so,
so when you see a creature like that,
you think,
yeah,
it's no wonder you're a bit cracked and
you know,
maybe somewhat dangerous,
but it's like,
man,
you've got the motivation for it.
So,
you know,
little understanding might be an order,
when I see people who are agoraphobic,
hey,
come and say to me,
well,
I've become afraid of everything.
I think,
ah,
that's easy to understand.
I just can't figure out how the hell it
was ever any different than that.
How did you ever manage to not be afraid
of everything?
Because that's the question.
You know,
and that's the fundamental existential
question too.
When you're surrounded by infinite
vulnerability,
how the hell can you stay calm?
Well,
you know,
part,
there's a bunch of answers to that.
We've explored some of that partly is
where you organize yourself with
everybody else.
So the chaos is at least held at bay,
you know,
you're not confronted every single
second with the possibility of insanity
or disease or death.
You could put some distance between you
and that.
And that's not an illusion.
It's like,
you know,
you don't want to spend the night in a
hospital room where an epidemic of Ebola
is raging and that's not a psychological
problem that you just don't want to be
there and intelligibly so,
so even putting any distance between you
and that outcome isn't the losery,
but then then there's the other things
that we do too,
which are,
which is try to find meaningful things
within the confines of our own lives and
the destructive and nihilistic
philosophies basically always claimed
that that's delusional and I don't
believe that.
I think that's wrong and I think it's
dangerous and I think it's almost
everything that students are taught in
universities and so over the last 10
years it seemed to me to be in.
Maybe this is an overstatement,
but the university education in the
humanities and often in the social
sciences causes more harm than it does
good.
You know,
because this is basically what it
teaches students at a point in their
life where instead of confronting the
radical uncertainty underneath
everything is that,
you know,
you should be invited into life.
Helped find a niche that's fulfilling
from a human perspective,
master that and then you know,
maybe start thinking about extending
yourself a little bit beyond that,
into the unknown,
but to take people who hardly know what
the hell they're doing to begin with and
then expose them to
a postmodernist,
ultra rational,
fundamental critique of everything.
It's like,
what do you expect is going to happen
when people have that experience?
Plus I think it's.
I think it's wrong.
That's the worst of it.
I don't think it's factually true.
I don't think it's philosophically true
and I think it's dangerous.
That's a bad combination.
And you know,
part of the reason I think that people
do this and are such admirers of
postmodern nihilism is that it abdicates
the necessity of responsibility.
You know,
because people say,
well,
I'm just thinking it through.
It's like you're never just thinking
something through the probability that
motivation has nothing to do with that
is zero because we already know just
from the things we covered in this
class,
that motivation frames your perceptions.
You know,
you can't even see the damn gorilla when
you're counting the basketballs.
And so,
you know,
if you're formulating a rationalist,
a critique of everything and then you
say,
Oh,
well I'm not motivated.
It's like while you're motivated,
when you count the basketballs,
and so the probability that you're
motivated when you're doing something
far more extensive and difficult,
and that is 100 percent no human would
say
know this is when we get back to the
mythological underpinnings of things as
well,
you know,
in the,
uh,
Egyptian
myth of creation and reality.
Oh,
cyrus is the figure of tradition.
So he sort of represents the dominance
hierarchy roughly speaking in all of its
manifestations.
And he has an evil brother named seth.
Seth is a typical figure in fairytales.
You know,
in the lion king you see scar who's
exactly the same figure and the scar
sort of seth figure stands for the
proclivity of bureaucracies to
degenerate into look malevolent,
totalitarian states,
which is always a problem,
right?
Because they,
a rigidity fly and then press,
that's the price you pay for existing
within a hierarchy.
And then they rigidified Oh,
press sometimes because that's just what
happens as the age.
And sometimes because there's a a voice,
I'm recommending that as a motive being,
it's okay if you do this,
it's okay if you break this rule,
you know,
what the hell difference does it make
any ways you see some of that being
played out right now with the revelation
of all those Panama papers.
Right?
So,
which is a huge revelation of corruption
at hardly surprising at high levels of
power all around the world.
Now I see the
no at the bottom of everything.
So this is the archetypal Dabs I see
this battle in the human soul,
basically between an attitude that says,
despite its limitations,
life is valuable and worth preserving
and improving as proposition one and
proposition is the suffering that life
involves,
renders it ethically untenable and
physiologically and psychologically
unbearable.
And as a consequence of that,
it should just be eradicated.
And so it's a binary choice is some
sense,
yes to be in or no,
and you know,
you can,
you can conjure up powerful arguments on
both sides of that.
But to some degree your whole being is
an argument between those two questions.
You know,
and one of the things that young said,
which I think is extremely worthwhile,
is that you should figure out what
archetypal forces are in charge of your,
of your ba because they're there whether
you know it or not.
Now you know,
we've walked through that with some
detail.
You could look at it in a sense from a
biological perspective,
it's more mechanistic.
You know,
when you're a tool of hunger and anger
and fear and love and loss and all those
primordial forces that
that
make up your field of experience.
That's a purely biological way of
thinking about it,
more architectural way of thinking about
it.
Just that those things are actually
characters or personalities and they're
organized into hierarchies that are also
characters and personalities.
You know,
an anger and fear and resentment and
hatred and carton.
You know,
the carnivorous soul of human beings and
all of those things aggregate into one
form of Metta personality and all the
things that you might think about as
existing in opposition to that aggregate
into another.
And then the.
The top most struggled for integration
is a struggle between those two things.
That's a very common mythological theme,
you know,
that's basically the battle between good
and evil in heaven
and that's an unbelievably old.
It's a.
it's a.
it's an old idea as human beings have no
the battle of the gods for dominance and
habit,
even if it's not strictly between good
and evil.
You know what?
Even if it hasn't been developed to the
point of that ultimate opposition,
it's still a battle at some level
between titanic forces for domination.
Well,
that's partly a description of your own
psyche and partly a description of the
organization or lack thereof of
societies across
time and.
Well,
and it seems to me that that one of the
things young was insistent upon because
he was trying to,
and many of the fingers that we've
covered in this,
in this series,
you know,
they were,
they were trying to answer the question.
This was especially true for the
clinicians of how it is that an
individual should conduct themselves so
that their mode of being is optimized.
You could say,
well that's mental health,
but that's.
It's a radically insufficient way of
describing that because,
well,
it's not merely the absence of
pathology,
it's something much more complex.
That's something active and it's not
even individual.
It's individual and social,
you know,
because you're not going to be mentally
healthy unless you're integrated into a
functioning social community.
You just can't do it because other are
part of what keeps you sane,
you know,
because they're always whacking you.
When you get out of line a little bit,
they just tap you with sarcasm or raised
eyebrows or frowns or smiles or they're
constantly tapping you into being a
proper person.
Whatever the hell that is,
you know,
but they're telling you all the time
what it is.
So
you know,
so niches.
Idea was that the modern world had
landed itself in hot water because it's
own proclivity for searching out.
The truth had undermined it's faith in
traditional axioms of morality.
Fair enough.
That seems about right.
You know,
and his cure for that was that people
became,
he called it over.
Men often translated as superman,
which were people who created their own
values to fill the void left by the
absence of traditional values,
but there's a bunch of problems with
that idea.
One is individuals probably can't do it
because they don't live long enough,
and second,
it's really hard.
I mean just from my perspective of what
are you going to be the best philosopher
who ever lived because that's really
what it requires and then the third
problem is what makes you think you
create values?
Like it doesn't phenomenologically
obvious that you do.
It's more like you experienced them and
sometimes you don't even know where they
came come from.
You get angry.
Do you know why?
Maybe you'll have to think about it for
like three days.
So in what way you created that as well.
It's not self evident and young's idea
was,
well,
the forces that we had regarded as
traditional sources of values,
we're actually spontaneous constructions
of the human psyche.
They weren't arbitrary systems of rules.
They were way deeper than that and I
think if you have an ounce of biologist
in you,
you immediately read that and think,
well,
yeah,
obviously,
obviously you know,
even the social rules that govern a
dominance hierarchy,
like they're instilled in you,
you know them,
they're right in your body,
and so there's a biological basis for
your understanding of culture right at
that level that's damn near spinal,
like it's old.
So you,
secondary proposition was,
and this is quite an interesting one,
is that by attending to your fantasies
and your dreams and your daydreams for
that matter,
you can come into contact with some of
the primordial psychic forces that
originally produced religious revelation
and so that you can find what's lost by
looking within,
you know,
and that's basically the entire point of
union psychotherapy.
And part of the reason I'm concentrating
on young is because guys like Rogers,
you know,
and the phenomenologists they're,
they're,
they're moving down the same trail of
thought,
but they didn't get as far as young as
far as I could tell.
Like they never took it to its ultimate
conclusion.
You know,
like maslow for example,
talk about a hierarchy of needs and the
self actualized person was someone who
had accomplished all those basic needs
and popped out at the top.
It's like
kind of true,
but sort of primitive,
you know,
because it is by no means obvious that
you have to take care of all your basic
material needs before you can act
morally.
It's a foolish idea.
It assumes that people are going to get,
like they're going to be become more
moral as they get richer now.
Like I'm not saying they become less
moral because I don't believe that,
but I don't see that there's any
positive association.
It's just you can use it,
you can use your wealth well or you can
use it badly just like you can use your
poverty well or use it badly.
So.
So maslow,
it's like,
yeah,
there's a hierarchy.
Yes,
something emerges at the top.
No,
it's not a consequence of the
fulfillment of needs.
It's way too materialistic.
It's basically like a utopian select,
a utopian socialist idea,
right?
If you feed people enough cake,
all of a sudden everyone will get along.
It's like people aren't like that at
all.
So you took this idea of personal
development as far as I can tell to its
ultimate extreme to its logical
conclusion and that's where he ran into
the archetypes because what archetypes
are in some sense is the ultimate
instantiation of an idea.
You can't go beyond.
That's why it's an archetype,
you know?
So there's an archetype of death.
Well why?
Well,
because he can't go past that.
Like words fail when you're confronted
by that and there's an archetype of love
and you know,
there's an archetype of evil and all of
those things are there beyond
articulation and in,
in their archetipal form.
And they are the place where you're
articulated thought ceases to be
relevant.
So for young,
you know,
the self development
route was the confrontation of those
things that you had abandoned within.
Now I've been thinking about young for a
very long time and I think that one of
the things that struck me about the
cycle analyst is that they're much too
concerned about the idea that if you're
properly properly organized as a human
being,
that organization is interest psychic.
Like it's in you somehow,
and which is,
uh,
you know,
so for young,
the hero's journey was a journey into
the unconscious and individual journey
into the unconscious.
Now he,
he started to see flaws in that idea as
he moved forward with this thinking.
But one of the flaws in that idea is
that you're not only individually not at
all and if you're,
if you're situated properly,
we'll say in being your relationships
are healthy as well as the proper
balance being struck inside you between
the competing sub personalities that
make you up.
And those things are actually not
different.
And you know what I mean,
you can't have one without the other.
So to think about them even as separate
spheres is improper in a sense because
you're limited in your wellbeing by the
wellbeing of those people who are,
you know,
in concentric circles around you.
And no matter how well organized you are
internally,
it's insufficient.
No,
you see that reflective in stories like
the story of the Buddha because at one
point the Buddha after being walloped by
knowledge of old age sickness and death,
because that's really what does it mean
he attains enlightenment under a tree
for variety of reasons.
We won't go into,
you know,
so he's attain the perfect state of
primarily subjective Ba and that's sort
of like,
it's a temptation.
There is a temptation to remain there,
but he shuts that down and then goes
back into the world and teaches people
because his realization is nirvana
attained individually is not true.
Nervana,
you can't be not suffering in a sea of
suffering.
You know,
all that means is that you've got a
particular kind of blinder on and so you
know,
he goes back so to speak and then
suffers.
No,
mythologically speaking suffers a normal
human death.
And in some sense that's portrayed as
voluntary.
So
sometimes I show People Pinocchio in
this class.
I think we did a little bit of that.
Did we do a little bit of that?
Well,
you know,
in Pinocchio,
Pinocchio was trying to become a real
person and he have to do a variety of
very strange things to manage that,
one of which is to go down into the
depths of the ocean and confront the
most frightening thing roughly speaking
and simultaneously rescue his father,
which is a very,
very strange set of ideas.
You know?
It's definitely a descent into the
underworld.
There's elements of Jonah and the whale
in there.
I was very,
very old story,
but there's an idea that's very much
associated with union thinking too.
And that is that in the in the
background chaos of your mind,
there are depths and in those depths are
what the forgotten or non articulate
structures of your culture.
But more than that,
the forgotten or non articulate parts of
your psyche that would make it a
cultural,
a culture creating entity.
And that that has to be discovered in
order for you to be.
To have the courage to be an individual.
And there's nothing delusional about
that.
You know,
because the idea there as opposed to say
the typical nihilistic or terror
theories is that if you got your act
together,
the fear of death would no longer be the
thing that fundamentally rules you like
that.
That's actually possible.
So there's a weird idea there and the
idea is not the fear of vulnerability in
death is irrelevant or not.
Not even that it's not central,
but that people are so God damn tough
that it's possible that they can face
that directly and say that's not going
to be what rules my life.
And I believe people can do that.
I've seen people do that certainly in
their careers.
You know,
even if they can't articulate that
philosophy,
you put them in a situation where
they're doing nothing but dealing with
death and destruction and you know,
they can do it,
which is mind boggling and a great thing
to be able to see.
And it's,
you know,
you search in vain throughout the annals
of psychology for optimistic ideas.
And I think that's particularly true
with regards to like the more
experimental brands of psychology that
are associated with being like social
psychology personality.
We'll leave out of this for the time
being because it's become more
statistical,
you know,
but the idea that there's enough in you
so that if you don't flinch from life,
you can become strong enough to master
it.
That's an amazing idea.
It's the only optimistic idea I've ever
seen that's profound,
that I absolutely believe has most of
the profound ideas that are easy to
believe are terrible ideas,
you know,
they have to do with the inevitability
of malevolence and death and insanity
and suffering and all of that.
You know,
those things kind of blow through your
persona.
But trying to find something optimistic
to counterbalance that.
That's tough.
But you know,
the other thing we know about people now
that we didn't know a few years ago
is that
if you put yourself in new environments,
you actually change yourself
genetically.
You know.
So if I take you out of your safe
environment,
start to expose,
you,
say to situations that you fear.
You could say that one of the reasons
that you transform is because you
observe yourself mastering those
situations,
you know,
so you get bigger,
so to speak in the situations,
get smaller,
lovely.
You can,
you can,
you can account for that by learning,
but there's an additional dimension that
might be related to the learning,
which is that if you put yourself into a
new situation,
then different proteins start to be
encoded in your brain and you know,
and the rest of your nervous system,
so you actually transmute,
literally speaking,
and the total range of human
transmutation is unexplored.
So there's this idea.
Let me show you.
This is a cool thing to know about.
Um,
okay.
So that's a picture of a labyrinth at,
in the shark feed federal.
Now a cathedral is shaped like a cross
and then the focal point of the
cathedrals right at the middle of the
Cross and the cross is an x,
so to speak,
in the center of the x is where you are.
And the reason it's a cross between this
because of the center of that x is
suffering.
And so the central aspect of
consciousness,
of being his integrity associated with
suffering,
betrayal,
all of those things,
that's the nature of the center of the
world.
And so then the question might be,
well,
how do you cope with that?
Well,
the typical religious ideas that you
identify with a hero figure of some sort
and although that's often warped and
morphed into the idea that you believe
in them,
that's not what.
It's not the right idea.
The right idea is that you identify
with.
So I can give you an example from that
in the Christian mass ceremony,
which is actually a cannibalistic ritual
and it's a very,
very old idea,
and the idea is that you become what you
ingest,
right?
And so it's the mass ceremony which is
in principle,
the eating of the flesh of a god is not
a ritual to instantiate articulated
belief.
It's a ritual to instantiate embodied
transformation.
You're supposed to become what that
represents.
Question is what the hell does it
represent?
What we know?
Some of that it represents,
for example,
the ability to pay attention.
That's one thing that for sure it
represents because Christ is an analog
of of Horus,
a very tight analog horse as a matter of
fact.
So,
but what else does it represent?
Oh,
I can give you some other suggestions.
One of the things that is often required
of the believer in a traditional
religion is a pilgrimage right now that
was quite common in Christianity in the
Middle Ages.
That's kind of disappeared.
You see bits and pieces of it in Judaism
with the idea of modern Judaism in
particular,
with the idea that every North American
Jew,
for example,
she'd go to Israel at least once and
then of course it's a massively featured
element of tradition,
traditional Islam.
So you think,
well,
what does a pilgrimage dude is someone?
Well,
partly it's a journey to the holy city.
Whatever that means.
The holy city is a symbolic
representation of an ideal mode of
being.
So you're.
You're making a symbolic journey to an
ideal mode of being.
Okay,
well,
let's say you're some ratty villager
from somewhere and you've never been
more than a mile away from your,
from your village,
and you're functionally illiterate.
You don't know anything about the world
in one day you decided to,
you know,
take up $1,500 or 3000 mile pilgrimage.
The probability that you're going to be
the same person when you come back as
you were when you left is zero,
and the reason for that is,
well,
a lot of things are gonna happen to you
along the way.
God only knows it's gonna be a big
adventure and you might say,
well,
what's the utility?
And that utility is that,
you know,
with each stressful situation you
encounter and master your,
your capacity grows,
and so maybe you'll encounter 500 of
those on your pilgrimage.
Maybe you don't even,
you know,
maybe it's dangerous enough so there's a
reasonable probability that you won't
even come back alive.
But if you do come back,
you're not naive.
You've seen the world.
You're going to be someone who's much
more difficult to contend with.
You know when you're going to be a bit
of a forerunner to the people in your
village price,
you pay for that member in the hobbit.
When billable goes out to confront the
dragon,
then he comes back,
no one really likes them anymore,
like they respect them,
but they think,
well,
you know,
here's this weird guy that transformed
himself into like a thief and you know,
then when confronted a drag and he went
way the hell away from his home,
so he started contaminated by the
foreigner and he made it back.
You don't want to mess with him,
but he's not the same thing that he was
when he was there,
you know?
And that's all to the good.
I mean what happens in the next series
of books that makes it quite evident
that if Bilbo hadn't undergone his
adventure,
than the battle between good and evil
would have gone to the evil side.
Right?
That's the entire plot of the Lord of
the rings.
It's this massive fantasy of good versus
evil,
just like Harry Potter and those things
like those ideas never go away.
You see that with the avengers too.
You know,
in the,
the one of the scenes in there is
extremely interesting.
You know,
so there's this scene,
this is where the,
what do they call those foreign alien
things,
Qatari or something like that,
you know,
the big monsters that come through the
portal and then invade New York.
I don't remember what they're called,
but there's a very interesting scene in
there where the,
uh,
armed forced to send a hydrogen bomb to
take New York out because of the descent
of these terrible aliens,
right?
And iron man who's this weird android
things.
So he's a human being that's
transforming himself into something
that's more than a human being.
One of the things that happens with iron
man suit gets increasingly gold as the
series continues.
There's a real reason for that.
He makes a personal sacrifice to avert
the hydrogen bomb,
right?
And then it blows up all the bad guys
and he falls to Earth just like ICARUS.
So that's pretty cool.
And then what's really interesting is
that when he falls to earth and he's
dead,
it's the whole or wakes them up.
And the reason for that is that like the
hulk represents masculine energy that's
completely unbound,
you know?
And then Tony Stark is this sort of
tightly constrained intellect character
who's half machine,
he's not enough savage,
that's one way of looking at it.
And so when he's lying there half dead,
he's missing something.
And so the whole comes along and like
yelled at them into being again and he's
already made a relationship with the
hulk.
Right?
And these things are genuine myths
because they're cocreated with their
audience.
You know,
all of these stories has a backstory.
And if you're a comic book writer and
you deviate improperly from the
backstory,
then you're going to get like 10,000
letters from fans.
Say,
well,
what about issue 118 on page 13?
You know,
that's part of the necessary plot.
Well
alright,
keep Tony Stark in mind for a minute.
Now you see this labyrinth here.
So I'll tell you what you do in the
Shark Cathedral.
So you've got this cross.
And then this thing is at the point of
it.
Now,
if you go on a pilgrimage,
you go out there and expand your
personality by visiting the north part
of the world in the west part of the
world of the east part of the world,
in the south part of the world.
You go everywhere you are a wanderer
that's gone everywhere.
Okay,
but maybe you can go to the damn
pilgrimage for one reason or another,
so you do a symbolic pilgrimage.
She'd go to the cathedral and you go to
the point of suffering,
so to speak,
and then you enter this maze and to get
to the middle of the maze,
which is very much like the Buddha,
the flower of the that the Buddhist sits
in because it's a flower to get to the
middle,
you can't just walk straight to the
middle.
You have to wonder the entire maze and
cover every square foot of it and only
once you've done that,
so that's a symbolic journey to north,
east,
west,
and south.
Only after you've done that,
do you get to the middle and the middle
signifies the point where the suffering
that's represented by the entire
structure of that building.
Can Be with stood and you know,
you got to understand this idea is so
you think about what those damn
Europeans were doing when they were
building those cathedrals.
You know,
some of those things took 500 years to
build.
You can't even imagine a modern society
building something that would take 500
years to build,
you know,
it's,
it's unimaginable to us.
So,
and these cathedrals were so expensive.
They were like the moon,
the trip to the moon in the 19 sixties,
you know,
the whole damn culture was devoted to
producing these fantastic structures of
stone in light that had this particular
message embodied in it.
It's like,
why were they doing that?
Well,
you know,
you can get cynical about it,
although I think that'd be a little
premature,
but this is part of the answer.
It's like the culture was trying to
figure something out and what they were
trying to figure out is where you should
be and how you should get there.
And,
and,
and to point out as well how massive the
consequences were of failure versus
success.
Because failure that leads to hell and
success that leads to heaven and you
know you can think about that as
something projected into the,
into the future life which nature called
the biggest error Christianity ever
made.
But if you dispense with that,
at least provisionally,
you know the reality of that becomes
clear right away.
What happens if you don't take the
voyage while you become corrupt as your
week?
It's as simple as that.
And as soon as you and you have every
reason to become corrupt,
like you can say,
the conditions of existence are such
that if you cannot tolerate them,
you will become corrupt.
And I just,
I just can't see in any way how that's
not self evidently true.
And so if you don't take the voyage,
well what happens is everything tilts
towards hell around you,
but you have a lot more influenced than
you think.
So you don't know exactly what waves of
causality or emanating from your
decision.
So you have no idea,
you know?
And then if you do just start to go
everywhere and to pick up your
responsibility,
then what emanates out from Jojo.
And no,
maybe in receiving waves is the idea
that it's possible to live life properly
and to make things better.
And
that's an idea.
Like I think that idea is more powerful
than death
and it would be really good if that was
the case.
You know,
they existential element comes in and I
guess this is also the element of faith
is the only way you're going to ever
figure that out is if you try it because
no one else can demonstrate,
you know,
the truth or falsity of those two
branching pathways except you because
you have to test it in the conditions of
your own life.
You know.
And at some point by the time you hit
about 30,
nobody can tell you what to do and you
think,
well hooray.
It's like let's go a little easy on the
celebrating.
You know,
it's quite a relief when you have a
problem and you can go to someone and
they say,
well here's what you can do about it.
But by the time you're fully adult,
your damn life is so individualized that
you know you can use moral guidelines
and you should for sure,
but you're basically stuck with the
choices.
All these old ideas.
They suggest that
if your choice is to voluntarily
confront and to improve and to repair,
that not only do you repair the things
around you,
they don't have to be within you.
They can be anywhere around you and you
continually healed the structure of
being well.
That'd be a good thing to try.
You know it's a big deal.
It'll keep you busy in all.
It'll provide you're suffering with some
meaning.
That's a big deal and the alternative
looks dreadful.
Well,
you know,
I walked you through all these various
theories,
some of them about behavior and some of
them about personality and some of them
have both philosophy and some of them
about clinical psychology.
You know,
when it's an attempt to to allow you to
take multiple snapshots of what a,
what a human being is,
and you know how we might manifest
ourselves.
For me,
knowing all those things has been
ridiculously useful,
ridiculously useful.
Far More practical than anything else I
ever learned,
you know,
and one of the advantages to knowing
about personality is that,
you know,
instead of reducing the individual to
some set of measurable phenomenon,
which I'm all for by the way,
it also expands your conception of what
the individual can be to an almost
unlimited degree,
you know,
so instead of something like,
instead of a human being,
some being something that has to waiver
and be crushed under the weight of its
own being,
you know,
a human being could easily be something
that could stand up and say,
yeah,
well I can handle that and I think
people can do that.
People are so damn tough.
It's unbelievable.
You know,
I've seen people go through things that
are just grinding terrible and
not only come out the other side but
actually put themselves together enough
to clearly be a forest that rescues the
culture and tries to improve the
structure.
And so like Ray,
for us,
if we could do that,
not more than justifies whatever,
you know,
horror horrors might be laid at our
collect at our collective feet.
So I would say don't underestimate
yourself,
you know,
and you guys all have a lot going for
you.
You know,
you're smart,
you're young,
you're reasonably conscientious,
and number of viewers are creative.
You have access,
tremendous access to technological
power,
you know,
so God only knows what you met might
manage to hammer yourself into over the
next 30 years or so.
But the more people that try to make
things better consciously rather than
worse,
the better off everything is going to
be.
That would be a hell of a fine thing to
aim for.
So
that's mostly what I've learned from
studying personality.
So
thank you very much for attending the
course.
And a
good luck.